Sie sind krank
und wollen nichts als leben.
Sie warten auf ein Organ,
das ein Verstorbener spendet.
Ein Leben geht zu Ende,
eines wird verlängert.
Die Organtransplantation
ist ein Eingriff, der bewegt.
Es geht um Ethik, Glaube,
Gesetz und Moral.
Um grosses Glück ...
Ich freue mich wie verrückt
auf diesen nächsten Abschnitt
in meinem Leben.
Und ich bin sehr dankbar,
dass ich das alles erleben darf.
... und um Ängste.
Was bedeutet die Transplantation
für die Empfängerinnen und Empfänger?
Wie genau läuft sie ab?
Wir hatten den Schnitt
um ca. 8.20 Uhr.
Und die Leber ist sehr schön.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Es braucht wahnsinnig Geduld.
Wie ist die Lebensqualität
nach dem grossen Eingriff?
Es geht um Warten,
Hoffnung
und vielleicht - Erlösung.
MIT TELETEXT-UNTERTITELUNG
Rougemont bei Gstaad.
Bruno Romang
lebt mit einem Kunstherz.
Die Akkus
trägt er in einer Tasche mit sich.
Seit 2004
leidet er unter Herzproblemen.
Von Jahr zu Jahr
ging es ihm schlechter.
Wenn es mir schlechter ging,
waren die Symptome
immer die gleichen:
Ich war immer sofort ausser Atem
und voller Wasser.
Und auch müde,
hatte keinen Appetit mehr.
Am Schluss habe ich nur noch
eine halbe Mango gegessen.
Mehr ging nicht mehr.
Vor einem Jahr verschlechterte sich
sein Gesundheitszustand rapide.
Im Universitätsspital Lausanne
bekam er als Überbrückung
ein Kunstherz,
auch Herzassistent genannt.
* Feine Saitenklänge *
Jetzt wartet der 41-Jährige
auf das Herz eines Spenders.
Manchmal denke ich:
"Warum gerade ich?"
Oder: "Die anderen haben es nicht."
Ja.
Oder ich denke manchmal auch:
"Ich möchte wieder so sein
wie die andern."
Einfach gesund, ohne den Apparat.
Aber nachher
sollte das wieder gehen.
Da bleibe ich positiv,
guten Mutes.
Bis zur Transplantation
braucht sein Herz Strom.
Das sind die Batterien,
relativ grosse.
Die lade ich.
So eine Batterie hält 12 Std.
Das ist der Apparat für die Nacht.
Hier habe ich ein Kabel.
Den lasse ich immer hier.
Dann reicht es mir bis in die Küche,
auf die Toilette
und in mein Zimmer zum Schlafen.
So hat man genügend Kabel.
Mhm.
Wenn man schnell gehen müsste,
wenn etwas ist,
wenn es brennen würde, müsste ich
zuerst die Batterie anschliessen.
Daran denke ich ab und zu,
aber in der Regel
passiert ja nichts.
Ohne Kunstherz droht der Körper
nachhaltig Schaden zu nehmen,
sodass er
den Strapazen einer Transplantation
irgendwann
nicht mehr standhalten könnte.
Vorher war das Herz,
die linke Kammer, ganz schwach.
Sie hatte fast zu wenig Kraft, um
das Blut in den Umlauf zu bringen.
Und jetzt, wenn die Turbine
immer konstant gleich dreht,
geht das Blut automatisch.
So habe ich wieder genug Blut.
Romang ist Patient
am Unispital Lausanne,
einem der sechs
Transplantationszentren der Schweiz.
Sein Fall gilt nicht als dringlich.
Für die Zuteilung der Organe
ist die Stiftung Swisstransplant
verantwortlich.
Das Kunstherz
gibt keine Priorisierung.
Er ist regulär auf der Warteliste.
Es ist klar:
Wenn es Komplikationen gibt,
kann das Zentrum
eine Dringlichkeit beantragen.
Wenn man Probleme hat
mit dem Kunstherzen
oder irgendetwas auftritt, wodurch
eine Lebensgefährdung entsteht.
Für Herrn Romang
ist die Situation insofern gut,
als sich die Experten in der Schweiz
gut austauschen
und die Zahl der Dringlichkeiten
viel tiefer ist
als im benachbarten Ausland.
Wir haben etwa ein Drittel
der Herztransplantationen,
die dringlich sind.
Zwei Drittel sind regulär.
Es ist ganz wichtig,
dass die Patienten am Kunstherz
eine Chance auf eine Zuteilung
eines Organs haben.
Die Wartedauer
spielt nur eine untergeordnete Rolle.
Priorität hat die Rettung
von Schwerstkranken.
D.h.,
dass Patienten auf der Warteliste
oft erst ein Organ bekommen,
wenn es ihnen ganz schlecht geht.
Bruno Romang wartet.
Die Gedanken
an die bevorstehende Transplantation
holen ihn immer wieder ein,
v.a. nachts.
Wenn ich studiere,
ist der Gedanke ...
... dass nachher
das Herz eines Fremden da ist,
das quasi eingebaut ist
in seinem Blut
und dann weiterschlägt
in meiner Brust.
Das ist der komischste Gedanke.
Etwas Fremdes, das in mir ist,
das nachher meines ist.
* Melancholische Klaviermusik *
So wie Bruno Romang sind
mehr als 80 weitere Herzpatientinnen
und Herzpatienten auf der Warteliste.
Die durchschnittliche Wartezeit
für eine Herztransplantation
beträgt zurzeit rund neun Monate.
Die Zeit steht still
für Katja und Martin Rast.
Die Stimmung ist gedrückt.
Trüb, niedergeschlagen, im Moment,
müde, nervös.
Es ist eine lange Zeit zum Warten.
Die Ungewissheit, wie es läuft ...
Du bist hilflos.
Du kannst nichts machen,
du kannst nur warten.
Ihre Tochter liegt im Operationssaal
für eine Lebertransplantation.
Zwei Wochen vorher:
Mireya lebt einen normalen Alltag.
Aber: Sie leidet unter einem
extrem seltenen Gendefekt.
Zweimal schon
erkrankte sie lebensbedrohlich.
Ein einfacher Infekt
wie ein Schnupfen
kann jederzeit wieder
ein akutes Leberversagen auslösen.
Der einzige Weg zur Heilung
ist eine Lebertransplantation.
Mireya ist auf der Warteliste.
Jetzt fängt der Stress richtig an,
weil sie
auf die superwichtige Liste kommt.
Dann weiss man nie,
wann das Telefon klingelt.
Dann müssen wir rennen.
Tatsächlich wird Mireya
nach wenigen Tagen schon aufgeboten.
Ein Helikopter fliegt sie
ins Universitätsspital Genf,
ins Schweizerische
Kinderleberzentrum.
Hoi.
Bist du etwas durcheinander?
- Mhm. - Ich verstehe dich.
Die Kinderchirurgin Barbara Wildhaber
versucht, Mireya zu beruhigen.
Aber auch für die Eltern
sind es schwere Stunden.
Sie sind in Todesangst
um ihre Tochter.
Weil sie von uns gehört haben:
Es ist ein Riesending.
Die Transplantation
beginnt um 11 Uhr am Mittag.
Jetzt müssen wir schauen.
Was ist das?
Vierte Etage,
zweite Wohnung.
Also.
Das Genfer Unispital
hat den Eltern für die nächste Zeit
eine günstige Wohnung
zur Verfügung gestellt.
Home sweet home.
Seit Jahren
leben die Eltern in Angst,
seit dem ersten Zusammenbruch Mireyas
in Bulgarien, Katjas Heimat.
Sie findet keine Ruhe.
Ich gehe mit einem gesunden Kind
rein und nachher ist sie so.
Krank. Jetzt ist sie wieder krank.
Ja, es ist komisch.
Eigentlich geht man
mit einem kranken Kind ins Spital
und kommt mit einem gesunden
wieder raus.
Nachher liegt sie wieder dort
mit Schläuchen, Maschinen,
Medikamenten und allem.
In der letzten Nacht
sind sie nach Genf gereist,
haben kaum geschlafen.
Jetzt müssten sie sich ausruhen.
Wenn es nicht anders geht,
nimmst du eine Beruhigungstablette.
Ist so!
Du machst dich kaputt und denkst,
du kannst für Mireya da sein?
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich denke immer, wenn ich schlafe,
verpasse ich etwas.
Du musst ja nicht
7 Std. am Stück schlafen.
Vielleicht 1-2 Std.
Aber Katja hält es nicht aus.
Sie will zurück ins Spital.
* Vereinzelte
melancholische Klaviertöne *
Barbara Wildhaber ist
die einzige Chirurgin in der Schweiz,
die Kinderlebern transplantiert.
Sie arbeitet daran,
alles für den späteren Austausch
von Mireyas Leber vorzubereiten.
Man will eigentlich
keine so schöne Leber rausnehmen.
Aber leider funktioniert sie nicht,
wie sie sollte.
Makroskopisch
ist die Leber ganz normal.
Aber enzymatisch, genetisch
eben nicht.
Schon in der letzten
schweren Krankheitsphase
lag Mireya hier in Genf.
Das war vor drei Jahren.
Damals hatten die Ärzte
kaum mehr Hoffnung für sie.
Ihr Gendefekt
ist effektiv extremst selten.
So selten, dass wir mit der
ganzen Welt gesprochen haben.
Die Erforschung der Krankheit
steckt noch in den Anfängen.
*  Melancholische Klaviermusik *
Inselspital, Haupteingang.
Mitarbeiter von Swisstransplant
bringen ein Terminal,
auf dem sich Besucher und Patienten
im nationalen
Organspenderegister eintragen können.
Das Register
gibt es seit gut einem Jahr.
Bisher haben sich aber
nur 70'000 Menschen eingetragen.
Drei davon
wurden effektiv Organspender.
Ob dieses Terminal
etwas daran ändert,
weiss heute niemand.
Mathias Nebiker hat schon oft erlebt,
dass die Angehörigen
nicht genau wussten,
ob ein Verstorbener
seine Organe spenden will oder nicht.
Organspende ist halt ein Thema,
das den Tod beinhaltet.
Und der Tod ist ein Tabuthema.
Es ist grundsätzlich ein Problem,
dass viele Leute
sich nicht gern damit beschäftigen.
Denn dann muss man sich auch
mit dem Tod beschäftigen.
Aber wie will man es sonst machen?
Ich sehe keine andere Lösung,
als dass man die Leute
darauf aufmerksam macht,
dass es diese Möglichkeit gibt
und dass es gut wäre,
man würde sich dazu äussern.
Denn sonst
müssen es die Angehörigen machen.
Und in dieser Situation
ist das schwierig und unangenehm
für sie und vielleicht auch
für das medizinische Personal.
Ob ja oder nein -
Nebiker wünscht sich einen
klaren Entscheid zur Organspende,
am besten schriftlich festgehalten.
In einem anderen Trakt
des Inselspitals
ist die Chirurgin Vanessa Banz
auf dem Weg zu einem Patienten,
der vor Kurzem transplantiert wurde.
Grüessech, Herr Cart. Guten Morgen.
- Frau Dr. Banz, guten Morgen.
Ca va?
- Viel besser. Ich bin froh.
Long time no see.
Rene Cart
hat mehrere Wochen Reha hinter sich.
Erzählen Sie! Wie geht es Ihnen?
Wenn ich anschaue,
wie ich bis jetzt ausgesehen habe,
sind es natürlich Welten.
- Ja.
Aber es war auch recht schwer.
Drei Monate ist es her, seit
Rene Cart eine Spenderleber bekam.
Weil er die seltene Blutgruppe B hat,
wagte er kaum mehr darauf zu hoffen
und konnte sein Glück kaum fassen.
Ich freue mich einfach wahnsinnig.
Es ist logisch. Es ist ein Geschenk.
Entschuldigung,
aber es ist wirklich ein Geschenk,
ich freue mich unheimlich.
Nach der Transplantation
kam Rene Cart an seine Grenzen.
Höllisch.
Es ist fast albtraummässig.
Ich war auch zwei-, dreimal
komplett neben den Schuhen.
Sie mussten mich arretieren,
weil ich durchgestartet bin.
Ich fühlte mich wie gefangen.
Irgendwie nicht existent.
Ich wollte mich bemerkbar machen.
All das wird mir eigentlich erst
jetzt im Nachhinein richtig bewusst.
Vanessa Banz
wurde mehrmals ans Bett gerufen
und stand ihrem Patienten bei,
wenn es ihm schlecht ging.
Klar, das ist schwierig.
Was mir hilft - das sage ich auch
immer wieder den Patienten:
Ich weiss,
diese Situation ist schwierig.
Sie können das nicht einordnen,
haben schlechte Träume.
Das vergeht.
Wenn man häufig transplantiert,
ist der Vorteil,
dass man immer wieder sieht
und weiss: Das ist vorübergehend.
Und das kommt wieder.
Aber für den Patienten,
der drinsteckt,
v.a., wenn es wirklich darum geht,
ihn zu arretieren,
damit er sich selber nicht verletzt
oder Schläuche rausreisst,
ist das hart -
auch zum Zuschauen.
Er hatte wenig Reserven.
Dann hatte er eine Transplantation,
die technisch problemlos war.
Die Leber hatte anfangs etwas Mühe.
Jemand, der krank ist,
plus eine Leber, die Mühe hat -
das ist keine ideale Kombination.
Aber das ist die Realität,
man kann nicht immer auswählen.
Entsprechend hatte er
einen holprigen Verlauf.
Der 63-Jährige
steckt noch immer in der Aufbauphase.
Er traut seinem Körper
noch nicht ganz.
Ich habe hier
zwischendurch leichte Schmerzen,
etwa auf dieser Höhe.
Aber nur kurz.
Sie haben einfach
nicht mehr viele Muskeln.
Die müssen Sie jetzt aufbauen.
Sie werden aktiver sein.
Sie werden sich mehr bewegen.
Das führt dazu.
Es ist einfach anstrengend.
Aber es geht schon viel besser.
- Ja, ja, auch zu Hause.
Ich bin zu Hause
mehr oder weniger selbstständig.
Ich kann mich gut bewegen.
Wer macht den Haushalt?
Haben Sie noch Unterstützung?
Meine Frau
macht zwischendurch noch etwas.
Gestern habe es zum ersten Mal
allein gemacht. - Super.
In kleinen Schritten
geht es zurück in den Alltag.
Rene Cart sieht wieder eine Zukunft.
Das erste, was ich jetzt umsetze,
sind Städtereisen mit meiner Frau,
in Städte, wo sie noch nicht war,
die aber absolut sehenswert sind,
z.B. Wien, Moskau, St. Petersburg,
aber auch Berlin.
Und sicher, was wir beide
gern zusammen machen: Ski fahren.
Was wir auch gemeinsam machen -
sie ist noch sehr aktiv,
ich momentan logischerweise nicht -,
ist 300-m-Schiessen.
Und ...
Vielleicht, da muss ich schauen,
je nachdem, wie es körperlich geht,
mache ich mit ihr zusammen
im Norden mal ein Mushing,
eine Schlittenhunde-Tour.
Frau Doktor, herzlichen Dank
noch mal. - Alles Gute, Herr Cart.
Es freut mich wirklich sehr,
Sie so zu sehen. - Vielen Dank.
Rene Cart kehrt zurück nach Hause.
Auf der Intensivstation
des Inselspitals
ist eine Patientin gestorben.
* Einzelne
melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Nebenan in einem Besprechungsraum
wartet der Ehemann.
Sie hatte einen Reitunfall.
Sie ist gestürzt
und mit dem Kopf
auf einen Baum aufgeschlagen.
Die Verletzungen
waren eigentlich harmlos,
aber sie hat
das Bewusstsein verloren
und ist dann am Erbrochenen
nicht erstickt,
aber sie bekam keine Luft mehr,
was zu einem Herzstillstand führte.
Sie konnte reanimiert werden,
aber die Schäden am Gehirn
waren zu gross.
Sodass sie jetzt nach zwei Tagen
im Inselspital verstorben ist.
Die Ärzte haben mit der Familie
gesprochen und es steht fest:
Die Frau ist Organspenderin.
Sie wird deshalb weiterhin beatmet.
Jetzt geht es darum,
den Hirntod offiziell festzustellen.
Die Frau ist tief komatös,
ohne Narkosemedikamente.
Es geht darum, nachzuweisen,
dass alle Hirnstamm-Reflexe
erloschen sind,
dass keine Funktion des Hirns
mehr da ist.
Damit beweist man,
dass die Durchblutung des Hirns
ausgefallen ist.
Dann würde ich
mit dem Kornealreflex weitermachen.
Die Ärzte prüfen, ob sich
das Auge der Patientin schliesst,
wenn es mit einem Wattestäbchen
berührt wird.
Ich auch nicht.
Mathias Nebiker
drückt auf gewisse Schmerzpunkte.
Keine Reaktion.
Ich sehe nichts.
Und er testet, ob sich der Kopf
reflexartig zurückdreht,
wie das
bei einem Schlafenden der Fall wäre.
Ich sehe keine Bewegung. - Nein,
ich sehe auch keine Bewegung.
Mit einem kleinen Schlauch
wird der Rachen berührt.
Normalerweise würde jemand husten.
Der Reflex bleibt auch hier aus.
Der Ablauf der Hirntod-Diagnostik
ist streng geregelt:
Zwei unabhängige Ärzte -
ein Intensivmediziner
und eine Neurologin -
müssen das Prozedere
gemeinsam durchführen.
Schliesslich wird der Beatmungstubus
1 Min. lang entfernt,
um zu klären, ob die Patientin
selbstständig atmen würde.
Ich sehe keine Bewegungen.
- Ich sehe auch nichts.
Dann schliesse ich es wieder an.
Alle Hirnstammreflexe
sind erloschen.
Die Patientin atmet nicht.
Beide Ärzte
unterschreiben das Protokoll.
Hier endet ein Leben.
Das ist der Todeszeitpunkt.
* Einzelne
melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Dank der Beatmung sieht es aus,
als würde die Frau einfach schlafen.
Kritiker der Organtransplantation
stellen infrage,
ob eine hirntote Person
wirklich nichts mehr spürt.
Dem Organspender werde
ein würdevolles Sterben verwehrt.
Der Hirntod ist eine Definition,
bei der ich legitim finde,
dass man das als Tod definieren darf
und die Voraussetzung schafft
für eine Organspende.
Es ist unbestritten,
dass nicht jede Körperzelle
die Funktion verloren hat.
Was klar ist:
Die Hirnfunktion ist erloschen.
Das Hirn ist nicht mehr durchblutet.
Das Hirn ist das, was uns ausmacht.
Hirntote Patienten
wachen nie mehr auf.
In Schock und Trauer
sehen sich die Angehörigen
mit der Frage nach einer Organspende
konfrontiert.
In diesem Fall hat sich die Familie
dafür entschieden.
Ich denke, das ist sicher
im Sinne meiner verstorbenen Frau,
weil sie im medizinischen,
tiermedizinischen Bereich tätig war.
Wir beide, meine Tochter und ich,
haben das Gefühl,
dass wir sicher im Sinn
meiner Frau Ulla entschieden haben.
Es brauchte auch
keine lange Überlegungszeit.
Ich glaube,
wir haben in ihrem Sinn entschieden.
* Sanfte Hackbrettmelodie *
Mit ihrem Entscheid gehört
Familie Wehrle zu einer Minderheit.
Nur 40 % der Angehörigen
entscheiden sich
in dieser Ausnahmesituation
für eine Organspende.
Zurzeit warten rund 1'400 Menschen
auf ein Spenderorgan.
(Bruno Romang) Dort unten
ist der Landeplatz der Gleitschirme.
Nach der Operation möchte ich
wieder anfangen zu fliegen.
Ich hoffe, es geht,
aber ich glaube schon.
Paragliding
war Bruno Romangs Leidenschaft,
bis ihn das Herz im Stich liess.
Jetzt verfolgt er die Wettkämpfe
auf einer App.
Das sind die X-Alps.
Das ist ein Wettkampf
mit Gleitschirmfliegen und Laufen
von Salzburg bis Monaco.
Quer durch die Alpen.
Hier kann man die Piloten verfolgen.
Jeder Pilot
hat eine andere Linienfarbe.
Hier fliegt gerade einer.
Der Schweizer ist am Laufen.
Gleitschirmfliegen
ist und bleibt für ihn der Traum.
Du bist draussen in der Natur,
kannst fliegen, frei wie ein Vogel.
Du kannst von oben hinunterfliegen,
siehst schon das Ziel.
Manchmal hast du Thermik,
sodass es hinaufgeht,
du kannst Distanzen fliegen.
Es ist schön. Speziell.
Der Alltag allerdings
holt Bruno Romang rasch wieder ein.
Ihn plagen finanzielle Sorgen.
Abklärungen bei Versicherung und IV
ziehen sich hin.
Es ging gerade tout juste auf
bis jetzt.
Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt,
an dem ich nichts mehr hatte.
Ich habe ein paar Rechnungen nicht
bezahlt. Die warten einen Monat.
Wenn du nicht arbeiten kannst,
bist du angewiesen auf das Geld.
Ich hätte nie gedacht,
dass es so weit kommt.
Ich hatte vorher immer meinen Lohn.
Es ist einem nicht bewusst,
dass man nichts mehr hat,
wenn man nicht mehr arbeiten kann.
Jetzt ist das Ganze am Laufen,
dann kommt es schon wieder gut.
Ja.
Die brauchen etwas Zeit im Büro,
bis sie die Papiere gemacht haben.
Jetzt ist ein halbes Jahr vergangen,
seit wir ihnen geschrieben haben.
Ja.
Am Universitätsspital Genf
hofft Katja Rast
auf eine Nachricht
aus dem Operationssaal.
Das ist das Schlimmste.
Du bist nur am Warten.
Wenn du geschlafen hättest,
wäre es anders. Für mich schon.
Wenn ich genug geschlafen hätte,
wäre es ein bisschen anders.
Ja, das auch noch.
Nebenan ist die Transplantation
in vollem Gang.
Non. Encore un peu.
Die Co-Leiterin
des Kinderleberzentrums,
Barbara Wildhaber, ist zufrieden.
Wir sind sehr glücklich.
Es ist alles bestens bis jetzt.
Es sieht schön aus.
Wir haben richtig Freude.
Das ist wahr, oder?
* Lachen *
Es gibt sogar schon
eine positive Überraschung:
Wir haben eine grössere Arterie,
als wir gedacht haben.
Darüber sind wir glücklich.
Konzentriert legt die Ärztin
Mireyas kranke Leber frei.
Die Spenderleber trifft erst ein,
wenn alles bereit ist.
Den Ärzten,
die sie bis jetzt behandelt haben,
können wir blindlings vertrauen.
- Mhm.
Das soll auch so sein,
denn du hast eigentlich
keine andere Wahl.
Du kannst nur vertrauen.
Was willst du machen?
Ja und wenn ...
Was sitzen denn Sie hier?
- Oh! - Warten.
Uh!
- Alles bestens.
Wir machen nur ein Päuschen.
Jetzt hatte ich fast
eine Herzattacke.
Ich bin erschrocken.
- Nein, nein, alles bestens.
Ist alles gut?
- Ja, ja.
Ja, ja!
Darum haben wir eine kleine Pause.
Wir haben gerade
von Ihnen gesprochen.
Entschuldigung.
- Schon gut.
Wir haben absolut nicht
mit Ihnen gerechnet.
Entschuldigung,
ich auch nicht mit Ihnen.
Ehrlich gesagt:
Wieso sind Sie da?
Weil sie diese Zone
nicht gerne verlässt.
Aber Sie dürfen doch.
Es geht immer noch ein paar Stunden.
Es geht bestens, so gut,
dass wir jetzt eine Pause haben.
Aha, okay.
- Ja, ja.
Jetzt gehe ich essen.
- Ja?
Nachher geht es los?
Die Leber ist noch drin.
Wir müssen auf die neue warten.
Jetzt haben wir
eine halbe Stunde Pause,
weil es so gut ging,
dass wir schneller waren.
Entschuldigung,
Sie hatten fast eine Herzattacke.
Ich kam gar nicht mit,
v.a. wegen der Kappe.
Es geht ihr supergut.
- Okay.
Gehen Sie in den Wald spazieren!
Es ist zwar nicht schönes Wetter,
aber dann haben Sie etwas Luft.
Es ist kalt, ja.
Gut, also, bis später.
- Ja.
Wunderbar.
- Dann gehen wir.
Ist jetzt gut? - Ja,
jetzt bin ich ein wenig beruhigt.
Katja Rast ist erleichtert,
obwohl die eigentliche
Transplantation noch bevorsteht.
* Einzelne
melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Jetzt ging es!
Hast du gesehen?
Ich lasse es lieber.
Ich kann das nicht.
Am Inselspital
laufen die Vorbereitungen
für die Organentnahme.
Anita Hurni ist eine der Organspende-
Koordinatorinnen der Insel.
Ich kontrolliere noch,
ob das Hirntod-Protokoll gut ist.
Sie leitet
den ganzen Organentnahme-Prozess ...
Das ist vollständig.
... und steht in ständigem Kontakt
mit den Hinterbliebenen.
Im Moment ist es so,
dass die Angehörigen
für jedes Organ eingewilligt haben.
Wir klären alle Organe ab,
d.h., wir werden
einen Herzultraschall machen.
Die Computertomographie von Bauch
und Lunge wurde schon gemacht.
Ja, das ist gut.
Die Empfängerzentren
wollen sicher sein,
dass sie für ihre Patienten
voll funktionsfähige Organe bekommen
und keine Krankheit
unentdeckt bleibt.
Es braucht Blutuntersuchungen
und Gewebetypisierungen,
um herauszufinden,
zum wem die Organe am besten passen.
Was hast du für eine Temperatur?
- Du kannst es dort ablesen: 34,3.
Die Wärmeregulierung des Hirns
funktioniert nicht mehr.
Habt ihr schon abgenommen?
- Die Mädels haben schon abgenommen.
Frau Wehrle, wir drehen Sie jetzt
noch mal auf die linke Seite.
Nicht erschrecken.
Die Kollegin wird sich
die Haut noch mal anschauen.
Es fällt auf: Die Pflegefachfrau
erklärt jeden Schritt,
obwohl die Patientin verstorben ist.
Dann legen wir Sie zurück
auf den Rücken. Nicht erschrecken.
Okay.
Das hat für mich auch
mit respektvoller Betreuung zu tun.
Sie ist für mich nach wie vor
Mensch mit einer Seele.
Absolut.
* Piepen *
Ja.
Wie lange bleibt die Seele im Körper?
Gibt es sie überhaupt?
Wird der Sterbeprozess
durch die Organentnahme gestört?
Auch wenn medizinisch alles klar ist,
für viele bleiben Fragen offen.
Die Koordinatorin erfasst alle
medizinischen Daten in einem System,
auf das auch die Transplantations-
spitäler Zugriff haben.
Dann wird Swisstransplant
eingeschaltet.
Also, hör mal:
Du hast ja gesehen,
wir haben einen Spender im System.
Das Problem ist:
Es ist nirgends
richtig dokumentiert,
wie lange sie wirklich
reanimiert wurde.
Petra und ich haben versucht,
es über den Daumen zu schlagen.
So kamen wir in etwa
auf diese 40 Min.
Nein, nein.
Dadurch,
dass das Pferd erschrocken ist,
ist sie kopfüber ins Gebüsch
oder auf einen Baum geknallt.
Ich weiss auch nicht genau, wie.
Swisstransplant
tritt in Kontakt mit den Spitälern.
Das Computersystem
hat für jedes Organ
eine Reihenfolge derjenigen Patienten
errechnet,
die zum Zug kommen könnten.
C'est un 3A,
puis groupe sanguin B.
Ihr seid auf der ersten Position
für die Leber.
Und auch für die Niere.
Du bekämst
die linke Niere offeriert,
wenn Genf sie abgelehnt hat.
Sie haben Avoid auf Position 1.
Ich hätte die Niere auf Position 4
zum Anbieten.
Ist gut.
Danke, bis später. Ciao!
Das Angebot läuft.
Pro Organ haben sie 1 Std. Zeit
für die Abklärung,
ob Grösse und Gewicht
überhaupt passen.
Ob der Empfänger transplantabel ist,
ob er gesund ist,
zu dem Zeitpunkt,
an dem man transplantieren würde.
* Telefon *
Swisstransplant, Doris Wyss.
Auch der Altersunterschied
zwischen Spender und Empfänger
sollte bei gewissen Organen
nicht zu gross sein.
Der aktuelle Stand ist, dass Zürich
auf Position 2 auch abgelehnt hat,
wegen des Altersmismatch.
Franz Immer ist Medical Advisor
von Swisstransplant.
Er gibt die Organe der Spender frei.
Für die Zuteilung
ist in erster Linie entscheidend,
wie dringend ein Patient
das Spenderorgan braucht.
Das ist aber nicht immer eindeutig,
Algorithmus hin oder her.
Ich war selber Herzchirurg in Bern.
Hatte ich einen dringenden Berner
Patienten, war er der dringendste.
Es ist für die Kolleginnen schwer zu
verstehen, wenn ein Organ da wäre,
das das Weiterleben des Empfängers
sicherstellen könnte,
und es letztlich
in ein anderes Zentrum
zu einem andern dringenden Patienten
geht.
Das sind oft
sehr schwierige Diskussionen,
die wir zum Glück
meist mit einem Konsens
zwischen den drei Zentren und mir
lösen können.
Aber in diesen Momenten
geht man nicht mehr ins Bett.
Man überlegt immer wieder -
wohl auch meine Kollegen:
"Habe ich richtig entschieden?"
Die Abklärungen
mit den Empfängerzentren
können 6-8 Std. in Anspruch nehmen.
In dieser Zeit wird die verstorbene
Patientin weiter beatmet,
der Kreislauf stabilisiert,
der Körper mit Hormonen versorgt,
die er nicht mehr selber bildet.
Nicht erschrecken, jetzt legen wir
Ihnen etwas unter die Beine. Okay.
Die Patientin wird gepflegt,
zugunsten der Organempfänger.
* Leise, melancholische Klänge *
Ist die Organspende
moralische Pflicht?
Oder ist es verwerflich, den Körper
zum Ersatzteillager zu machen?
Was soll nach dem Tod geschehen?
* Langer, tiefer Klavierakkord *
Herzpatient Bruno Romang
holt seinen Sohn ab,
der mit der Mutter
im Nachbarsdorf lebt.
Seit vier Jahren ist Romang getrennt.
Salut! Geht's?
- Oui.
Ciao.
* Kuss *
Chaud? Warm?
- Oui, il fait chaud.
Okay.
Der 10-jährige Remy verbringt
jedes zweite Wochenende beim Vater.
Je fais vite la tour.
* Gemächliche Zupfklänge *
Elle va a la Coop.
Non, ta maman, äh, grand-maman.
Gemeinsam besuchen sie heute
Brunos Bruder an seinem Arbeitsort,
einer Zimmerei in Gstaad.
* Sägegeräusch *
Hallo. Geht's?
Du kannst das
noch schnell fertig machen.
* Die Säge
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
Hier habe ich gearbeitet.
Ich möchte wieder
hierher zurückkommen,
wenn es geht nach der Operation.
Silvan ist 2 Min. jünger als Bruno,
sie sind eineiige Zwillingsbrüder.
Beide sind gelernte Zimmerleute.
Aber mit dem Kunstherz
kann Bruno nicht mehr arbeiten.
Es gibt lange Tage,
wenn du nichts machen kannst.
Man ist nicht beschäftigt,
die Kollegen arbeiten alle.
Deshalb komme ich ab und zu
am Nachmittag hier vorbei.
Um etwas zu plaudern,
den Chef zu grüssen.
Hier unten ist das Geländer.
Das wird sandgestrahlt.
Schön.
Als die Brüder noch gemeinsam
in diesem Betrieb arbeiteten,
nahm Silvan seinem Bruder
die schwersten Arbeiten ab.
Beide haben Herzprobleme,
beide sind unzertrennlich.
Wir machten den gleichen Sport,
das Paragliding
haben wir zusammen gemacht.
Im Militär
waren wir zusammen im Tessin.
Ja,
auch im Tessin waren wir zusammen.
Wir haben immer
alles zusammen gemacht.
Sogar die Fahrstunden.
- Mhm.
2010 hatte ich das gleiche Problem.
Ich war zuerst auf der Liste,
um das Herz zu wechseln.
Jetzt ist es ihm so ergangen.
Es ist schon speziell.
Jetzt ist der Zeitpunkt,
wo man es machen muss.
Ja.
Also gut.
Silvans Herz hat sich erholt.
Bei ihm ist die Transplantation
kein Thema mehr.
Und doch hat er das Hobby
Gleitschirmfliegen aufgegeben,
als Bruno aufhören musste.
Ohne ihn mache es keine Freude mehr.
Hier ist der Eiger.
Von dort
geht es direkt zum Mont Blanc.
Ils sont que cinq?
Auch bei Remy ist das Interesse
fürs Gleitschirmfliegen geweckt.
Ah!
Ich werde mit dem Ferienpass
Gleitschirm fliegen.
Ein Tandemflug.
Une biplace.
- Oui.
Oui.
Ich bin so normal,
wie ich sein kann.
Ich mache mir wenig Gedanken
mit ihm.
Wenn ich ihn habe,
rede ich über andere Sachen.
Aber was ich habe, weiss er schon,
dass ich mal
ein anderes Herz bekomme.
Er kam mich auch schon
im Spital besuchen.
Ja ...
Das war am Anfang hart für ihn,
das erste Mal.
Er hatte fast Augenwasser.
Aber jetzt geht es gut.
Etwas komisch mit dem Sack.
C'est bizarre avec la Sack?
- Non.
Non? Habitue?
- Oui.
On s'habitue.
Oui.
- C'est comme ca.
Apres, j'ai plus la Sack.
- Mhm, ca sera bien.
Remy musste sich damit abfinden,
dass vieles nicht mehr geht.
Früher gingen wir oft
nach Charmey ins Thermalbad.
Wir haben
viele solche Sachen gemacht. - Mhm.
Pilze suchen,
chercher des champignons,
promener, wandern,
im Winter gingen wir Ski fahren.
Aber schon lange nicht mehr.
Apres je peux.
- Mhm.
C'est a toi.
- C'est a moi? - Oui.
Bist du sicher? - Oui. Moi,
je ne peux plus. J'ai eu le rouge.
Alle Hoffnung ruht auf der
bevorstehenden Herztransplantation.
Jetzt sehne ich mich fast
nach dem Moment,
wenn die Operation kommt und ich
mich nachher wieder aufbauen kann.
Und dass ich nachher wieder gut bin.
Am Anfang
hatte ich schon Angst davor.
Jetzt gehe ich einfach und ...
... hoffe, es komme gut.
* Einzelne Saitenlaute *
Auf dem Dach des Schweizerischen
Kinderleberzentrums am Unispital Genf
trifft die Leber für Mireya ein.
Mireya und ihre Eltern
werden nie erfahren, woher sie kommt.
Der Spender bleibt anonym.
Für die Empfänger
könnte es belastend sein,
Details zu den Todesumständen
zu erfahren.
Nur so viel ist klar: Es handelt sich
um einen Teil einer Erwachsenenleber.
* Pulsierende Klavier-
und Streichklänge *
Achtung, die Leber rutscht.
Uh la!
Il est beau.
Die Leber ist das einzige Organ,
das sich auf zwei Empfänger
aufteilen lässt.
Wunderschön! Wunderschöne Leber.
Das richtige Gewicht,
wie wir uns das vorgestellt haben.
Die Gefässe sind schön.
Wir sind im Moment glücklich.
Jetzt wird es langsam
tack, tack, tack.
Jetzt kommt die Leber
aus dem kalten Wasser
in den warmen Körper von Mireya.
Das müssen wir schnell machen.
Dann spreche ich
nicht mehr schweizerdeutsch.
* Surren *
Die kranke Leber
wird erst jetzt herausgeschnitten.
Voila, voila. Je sais, j'ai compare.
L'autre clamp.
Magnifique.
Spülen, bitte.
Wegen des seltenen Gendefekts
wird Mireyas Leber
genau untersucht werden,
hier in Genf,
aber auch im Ausland.
Die Forscher erhoffen sich
Aufschlüsse über die Krankheit.
Jetzt geht es darum, die Spenderleber
mit Mireyas Gefässen zu verbinden.
* Sie spricht französisch. *
* Einzelne Saitentöne *
Während die Ärztin und ihr Team in
der heiklen Operationsphase stecken,
wird das Warten
für die Eltern zur Zerreissprobe.
Es ist nur so Zeug drauf,
Spezialtüren.
Vas-y, s'il te plait.
Die grösste Anspannung
scheint vorbei.
Barbara Wildhaber
spricht wieder schweizerdeutsch.
Das ist der grosse Moment
der Transplantation,
wo das Blut
wieder durch die Leber geht.
Sie ist momentan bräunlich,
wird aber gleich - so hoffen wir -
wieder schön rosarot.
Okay, tres bien. Schöne Leber.
Seid ihr einverstanden?
* Sauggeräusche *
Gut.
Sehr gut.
Es blutet nicht
und die Leber ist schön rosarot.
Jetzt bekommt sie noch die Arterie,
die gute Leber,
dann wird sie ganz zufrieden sein.
Aber die Leber lebt von den Venen.
Deshalb ist sie jetzt schon
sehr zufrieden
und wird Galle produzieren
und alles, was sie muss.
* Stetes Piepen *
* Leise, angespannte Klänge *
Ich sehe noch niemanden.
Kurz vor 19 Uhr,
8 Std. nach Beginn der Operation,
endlich die erlösende Botschaft.
Wir haben die Gefässe
einmal kontrolliert.
Alles fliesst gut.
- Und die anderen Organe?
Ja, wir sind wirklich froh.
Ach!
Danke.
Auf diese Nachricht
haben wir gewartet. - Ja.
* Lautes Aufatmen, Kuss, Lachen *
Was ist?
* Melancholische Klavier-
und Streichmusik *
Weisst du,
was für einen Stress ich hatte?
Bis die Eltern die Tochter
wiedersehen, vergehen weitere 2 Std.
* Gelöste Klaviermusik *
Hallo. Hallo, Mireya.
* Die Musik
übertönt das Gesprochene. *
Wenn du sie so siehst ...
Das macht dich gleich wieder fertig,
das Ganze.
(Flüsternd) Aber was willst du?
Sie muss durch.
Dann gehen wir auch durch - leider.
(Barbara Wildhaber) Kommen Sie!
- Ah, super.
(Barbara Wildhaber)
Das braucht es nicht.
Die Eltern wollen unbedingt
eine Maske tragen.
* Lachen *
Gehen Sie nur rein!
Ich erzähle ihnen rasch,
was wir gemacht haben,
und dann gehe ich.
Ich komme später vorbei.
Nur eine Frage: Sie erwacht selber?
- Ja.
Sie wacht selbst auf?
Sie wird erwachen,
wenn wir die Medikamente wegnehmen,
die machen, dass sie schläft.
Dann wacht sie auf.
* Gespräch auf französisch
im Hintergrund. *
Sie müssen keine Angst haben
vor ihr.
Nein, ich habe Angst wegen dem ...
- Wegen dem Schnitt?
Setzen Sie sich.
Kann er einen Stuhl haben?
Er hat Mühe, die Narbe zu sehen.
(Mireyas Mutter) Hoi, bravo,
du hast das super gemacht.
Super gemacht!
* Sie spricht bulgarisch. *
Mireya?
Mami und Papi sind da.
Das hast du super gemacht. Mega!
In der nächsten Sendung:
Nicola Heyser lebt seit fast
zehn Jahren mit einem Spenderherz.
Wenn ich schlechte Tage habe,
kommen manchmal schon Zweifel auf,
ob alles wirklich gut ist.
Aber ich sage mal:
Zu 98 % vertraue ich meinem Körper.
Die Chirurgin Vanessa Banz
ist unterwegs zur Organentnahme.
Man muss extrem vorsichtig arbeiten,
sodass man keine Verletzung macht,
die dazu führen, dass ein Organ
nicht transplantabel ist.
Und: Mireya kehrt zurück ins Leben.